Go back to my oncologist of the week, is there an alternative treatment for
Zomena? So Zomena is the drug that is an injection for people who have the
tassesses to the bone so it so I've spoken a lot of this in the past and I am
very much not a fan of this drug so I can't tell a person to take it or not to
take it but I'm not a fan of this drug because of the studies on the drug
itself they're just so unfavorable but they continue to use it which is kind of
mind-boggling to me so here's the deal with Zomena so when it first came out it
was a drug for osteoporosis so if you have osteoporosis they put you on Zomena or
can't remember what the other brand name at the time was it's an older drug
it's been out at least 15 years and it was just this great promise that it's
gonna help women with osteoporosis because if you have osteoporosis you have
weakening of the bone and then you end up with pathological fractures you know
you might have a mother who had a hip fracture while a person who has a hip
fracture didn't fall down and fracture their hip their hip fractured causing them
to fall down and their hip fractured because the neck of the fever is a very is the
weakest part of the of the bone of the weight bearing part of the whole
fever that neck of the femur and the the the strength of a bone is in the
inner part called the endosteum the outer part of the bone is called the periosteum
peribeens outer and means inner endosteum the inner part of the bone is really
where the the density of minerals are and that's what gives the strength to the
bone endosteum so if I have a lytic destruction of a bone due to due to it it
will start eroding away the periosteum and the endosteum and that's not good
because that can cause you know weakening of the bone and if it's a weight
bearing bone you can end up with a pathological fracture if I have the
tastasis to a rib the chance to be having a pathological fracture because the
ribs aren't weight bearing are are sliver though you can have you have a lot of
muscle pull on a rib and you can fracture a rib but it's more or so you'll
more so get a pathological fracture rib if you like hit it if you fall or you
beg it against something what do you could have pathological fractures are
going to be due to the tastasis to bone are going to be of the spine can be in the
hip but usually you don't have the tastasis to the fever of the hip so you
typically won't have that you get the tastasis to the pelvis which it's a very
big and dense bone the chance of you having a pathological fracture there is
pretty small it's really the spine that you're worried about so whether you
have osteoporosis causing weakening to the bone and then possible pathological
fracture or you have the tastasis you want to try to strengthen up the bone well
how do you deal with when you have a tastasis to the bone well you have to try to
attack the cancer so that the cancer stops growing right that's number one and
then from the medical doctor's perspective is hey we have this drug that was
approved for osteoporosis this somena why can't we use it for metastatic
cancers when you have that meds to the bone well great we'll start using it the
problem is the five-year studies which came out about 10 years ago on this
drug showed that women that used it for osteoporosis had no less pathological
fractures than women that didn't use the drug what the heck well that's what
it was trying to prevent his pathological fractures well all the studies and you
could google this google these studies all the studies show that all it did is
increase the density of the perilostium not the endostium so even the authors of
the study said that literally it's like wrapping saran wrap around the bone so
it's it's causing the periostium to become harder and actually in their words
more brittle and it's preventing calcium and minerals to get into the into the
endostium so it's causing a hard brittle cellophane wrapped or saran wrapped
periostium which the periostium doesn't give the strength to the bone therefore
it doesn't actually prevent pathological fractures why in the world are they
still using a drug to prevent pathological fractures when it doesn't
prevent pathological fractures because there's a whole lot of money in it and I
don't need to be cynical but I am just totally against Zilbeta and the other
brand names of this drug it does not increase the density of the endostium actually
it prevents the increase of density of the endostium because it wraps a brittle
you know wrap basically of calcium around the periostium sealing it up the
your bones are living matrix and calcium is going to in and out of your
bones all the time that's what helps balance your blood that's part of your
buffering system so you don't become acidosis is it steals calcium from the
bones calcium is going in and out of the bones you have osteoclastic and
osteoblastic activity constantly so I personally would not do Zilbeta I would
not use any of those classic drugs if I even if I had very serious metastasis
to the bone and weight-barried bone I would not do it and then I would do
radiation to the bone to kill the cancer if I had serious metastasis to the
spine I would not use any of this class of drugs